saluons la question en quoi y est assez
marrant alors cet aspect et cette odeur
là ça me rappelle un petit taureau n'est
qu'une machine rte
une mécanique de précision fascinante de
complexité un assemblage de pièces
d'horlogerie qui fonctionne à l'unisson
grâce à des organes et des fluides et
bobby sens de sophistication mais il est
aussi capable de produire des matières
auxquelles on aimerait ne jamais avoir à
faire est ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé
d'avoir comme une sorte de gêne dans le
fond de la gorge
un goût assez désagréable dans la bouche
puis de tousser et de cracher une petite
boule de pâte blanchâtre voir un peu
jaunâtre non enfin si c'est le cas vous
n'avez sûrement pas pu vous empêcher de
la tripoter et vous avez constaté
qu'elles se désagréger entre vos doigts
en laissant dessus une odeur absolument
dégueulasse
ces petites boules qui sont pas
forcément si petit que ça d'ailleurs
ce sont des tons si lolita comme on dit
dans le jargon littéralement des pierres
d'amygdales elle se forme dans des
cavités que certains d'entre nous au
niveau des amygdales et qu'on appelle
décrypte
c'est un mélange de cellules mortes de
bactéries et de résidus alimentaires qui
vont se loger dans ces cavités qui
macèrent qui ferment et qui forment
cette pâte qui donne extrêmement
mauvaise à l'aide qu'on appelle du cas
ces hommes en latin ça veut dire fromage
le fromage c'est comme on veut quand on
allez on change des tâches si je vous
dis ce magma vous me dites elles ont
perdu c'est pas un médicament contre la
diarrhée
mais c'est pas beaucoup plus appétissant
le cinéma c'est cette substance
blanchâtre pâteuse et souvent mal
odorantes qu'on retrouve volontiers dans
les plis nos parties génitales et qu'on
appelle communément du fromage de celles
qui sont devenus punisse et pourtant les
femmes produisent aussi du smig ma comme
les hommes grâce à des petites glandes
prévu à cet effet et oui parce que le
smig masse et pas juste là pour vous
mettre mal à l'aise pendant un premier
d'haïti ça sert à quelque chose d'un
composant de la fonction auto nettoyante
de notre petit matériel intime
d'ailleurs en latin et en grec ce magma
ça veut dire savons détergents nettoyage
c'est un mélange de la fameuse substance
sécrétée par nos petites glandes et de
cellules mortes
il joue aussi un rôle de lubrification
et même si on n'a pas encore tous bien
compris il pourrait participer à l'
équilibre de la flore génitale
ça pourrait même être une sorte de
signature odorantes personnel ce magma
numéro 5 de celle de diallo pas de
panique il suffit de nettoyer ça au
savon doux et à l'eau une fois par jour
et tout se passe bien
bon on descend encore d'un étage mais on
reste dans l'industrie fromagère avec le
grunge
la légende veut que ce terme désigne non
seulement un style musical mais aussi la
crème qui se niche entre des orteils
salle bon apparemment il ya que les
français qui appelle ça comme ça par
contre on néerlandais ont dit qu'ils ne
me cassent littéralement fromage
d'orteils peu importe comment ça
s'appelle mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette matière est un mélange de
transpiration est pour mortes qu'on
passait un certain temps enfermés dans
des chaussettes et des chaussures bien
acérées et qu'on finit par être colonisé
par des bactéries qu'il y trouve tout ce
dont elles ont besoin pour vivre et qui
sont responsables de l'odeur parmi ces
bactéries on retrouve des staphylocoques
des micros cox us et même des brévine
bactéries hommes qui sont de la même
famille que celle utilisée pour la
fabrication de certains fromages comme
le maroilles le munster ou la raclette
d'hommes avaient tous déjà produit
quelques cuillères et que ce soit dans
des boutons dans des plaies autour des
yeux ou dans un abcès
le pue c'est dans les king guerrier dans
la majorité des cas c'est le résultat du
combat de votre organisme contre une
infection il est composé de débris de
cellules des globules blancs qui luttent
contre les germes et de ces germes le
même des bactéries mortes ou vivantes
mais le plus n'est pas qu'une brute
il a aussi sa fibre artistique et il
offre une large gamme de couleurs et
d'odeurs
ça sent la noisette tout ça dépend
directement du germe en cause dans
l'infection ça va du blanc crème en
passant par le jaune le vert le gris le
brun
sans parler du sympathique bacille
pyocyanique qui propose quant à lui un
put d'une jolie couleur bleutée
on s'en débarrasser il faut un évacuer
la matière deux identifier le germe en
cause pour proposer un antibiotique
efficace mais tout ça c'est le médecin
qui s'en chargent fait pas les malins
fun fact il existe aussi du puce sans
germes qu'on appelle du pus aseptique
bon c'est dans certains cas particulier
du pus propres
bon allez avant de partir parce que je
pense aussi aux intolérants au lactose
vous prendrez bien une petite tartine de
tapenade
parmi les matières produites par votre
corps auquel vous n'avez probablement
pas du tout envie d'être confronté
vomissements fécales aux ide oui
vomissements comme vomir effet
qu'halloween comme comme ça et alors
attention avoir des vomissements fêter
halloween ça ne veut pas dire vomir du
cacao sens strict soyons précis disons
que les vomissements prennent l'aspect
et l'odeur des matières fécales
bon déjà rien que ça c'est pas très
conviviale
en réalité c'est plutôt dû liquider
sécrétion intestinale chargé de toute la
petite armée de bactéries fécales qui
remonte ce mélange au contenu de
l'estomac avant de ressortir par le haut
et si ça sort par en hausse et parce que
c'est bouché par en bas ça peut aussi
mais c'est rarissime être le signe d'une
fistule gastro coliques
ou alors une fistule c'est une espèce de
canal qui se crée entre deux organes qui
devrait pas communiquer entre eux
normalement donc là en l'occurrence une
fistule gastro coliques c'est une
fistule entre l'estomac et le gros
intestin
pendant tous les cas vous vous en doutez
c'est grave 1 donc la solution c'est la
chirurgie voilà btc c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo en attendant
continuer d'aimer votre corps est celui
des autres avec ses qualités ses petits
défauts mais qu'est ce que je vais dire
déjà eban appétit bien sûr
ah oui et surtout portez vous bien